videos of the of the panelists binder um
okay so we um
so while while that's being done um
let me just introduce the panel so so we
have a great panel uh
with um um
okay so so we have um
um
so all three all three people in the in
the panel work on
you know on cryptography and on uh on
protocol so um
let me let me start with uh zwika who is
who's shown up already he's uh
he works on
on fully homomorphic encryption uh he's
he's made it his
his
um
i guess mission to make it make fhe easy
efficient
you know easy to use he's also worked on
on
on on quantum aspects i guess we have
joined papers on on
on tests of quantumness and certifiable
uh
quantum random number generation and he
also has worked with on quantum garbled
circuits
um other panelists is uh ann brodman
who is um
from the
uh from the university of ottawa so
anne's uh worked on um on a number of
aspects of quantum cryptography i'll
just i'll just mention a few that have
been particularly
influential um
she's she has this paper on universal
blind quantum computation which was
which was particularly
influential in delegated quantum
computing
and she's worked worked a lot on um
on uh
issues of uh you know having to do with
zero quantum zero knowledge
and uh and on issues of composability of
quantum protocols
and our our third panelist is uh yael
kelly from uh who's who's a
senior researcher at microsoft research
in new england as well as an adjunct
professor at mit
so
in addition to all her the work on
cryptography she's she's she's also
worked on
delegated computation
um
including this very nice paper on
interactive computation for muggles
um i guess um
i i really got uh you know um
so one one of the first papers on having
to do with um you know at this border
between quantum and uh and uh crypto was
her paper with ron ross on
the power of no signaling proofs
so um
so let's let's start the panel with um
you know maybe three to four minute um
um you know
minutes for each panelist to to comment
on
on the talk as well as more generally on
this
on this intersection of uh quantum and
so
starting with
you know
please
i'll start
okay because you guys are quiet did you
want to start were you about to unmute
i i must hear you first
okay
because i've been waiting a long time to
say this uh first for me the talk was
unbelievable it was a real pleasure i
sat here i had a great time so thank you
and i learned a lot
uh but it got me thinking especially in
the beginning of your talk
which is you know we build cryptography
uh
which has traditionally been classical
and it's clear that we need to upgrade
and the question is how do we do it and
as you said okay move to lwe that's one
way or just move the post one secure
assumptions but clearly that's not
enough
and one thing that you talked about is
you say well now make go to all your
techniques and make sure you don't use
rewinding or if you use rewinding
make sure that it's compatible that you
can rewind the quantum adversary
but actually i'm not sure that's enough
i mean clearly you did you know you you
did a non-black box dive into the
killian protocol but let me explain what
kind of um
got me thinking in your talk
actually classically
i can prove that killian
the killian protocol is sound
with only two rewindings i don't need
polynomial windings and let me tell you
my proof
in my proof i'm gonna generate just i'll
rewind twice hopefully i'll get some
intersection in the pcb queries
and i'm hoping to get a collision
now if i get a collision with
non-negligible probability i won
if it's negligible
then in the analysis then i want to say
well if it's uh negligible then i i i
essentially i'm going to say if x is not
in the language it cannot be negligible
but that's kind of the proof so in other
words that the reduction in my the way i
i can think of killian my reduction only
rewinds twice
why the rewinding succeeds
in the proof of why the writing succeeds
i'm gonna quote unquote rewind many
times
so even if the
reduction only rewinds twice
it may work
i don't know i it's a thought-provoking
question it may work for classical and
may not work for quantum i don't know
it's um
it's anyway i want to have a
conversation around this i think it's a
kind of a basic uh
uh question in general for upgrading
crypto to post
post quantum crypto
um image can i respond or should be
please please do in this case yeah go
ahead yeah um okay so i think you're
talking specifically about like the
barack old drag proof strategy
because this proof is i think brock gold
right that you can do killian with two
rewinds one rewind actually right
right exactly i think my my perspective
on this is that
um mechanically what the proof is doing
is it's only rewinding once
um but the reason that you can show that
rewinding once suffices to find a
collision is only because
you can think of you can have this
thought experiment
where you're actually rewinding many
many times
and you use the fact that because
rewinding many many times works
this
necessarily implies because classical
trials are independent that something
will happen when you only do one trial
and so since all of this is a sort of a
thought experiment anyway like i guess i
don't see the the huge distinction
between like well i'm only mechanically
going to rewind once and then appeal to
like a thought experiment where i rewind
a million times
um and just saying like actually that
reduction is not really rewinding just
once right like and when you want to
phrase that as something you want to do
for a classical attacker or for a
quantum attacker then
truly like what you're using about the
attacker is the ability to query it many
times and like that that's why the the
brock goldberg proof actually doesn't
actually help you
uh prove the post quantum security of
killian but
i guess it's like maybe
maybe my answer is that it's like it's
kind of a matter of opinion of how much
that bad reduction is actually rewinding
because maybe it only does it once but
if it's relying on the fact that that
something would happen because you could
rewind it many times and it's not clear
to me it's only a one rewind reduction
so in other words i guess my point is if
i give you a proof that the r is
classical proof and in my classical
proof the i rewind only counts a number
of times and let's say i also have some
way using unrule unruly's technique uh
to you know take any such protocol make
it post quantum because if it's only
customer for wines we have ways to kind
of easier ways i think black box almost
ways to upgrade our protocols to be post
quantum rewind but that's not enough
because exactly of
you're saying well in their case maybe
in the
ex actually what's going on the proof
they do
so i guess my question is
do we have a black box way or is there
any hope of having a black box like a
general technique of saying look if you
have a classical proof it rewinds costs
a number of times we can take it
generically and make it post quantum
is there any hope or is that kind of
meaningless because in krypton because
in the classical world
we do rewinding in our analysis in some
sense
yeah i mean i think a lot of it would
depend on on uh like rewinding is such a
nebulous term right like it's unclear
what we mean when we say rewind um and
maybe maybe like
this uh like is for rock gold right
really rewinding once or not like that's
sort of a matter of uh how are you
defining the term
um
and so maybe like at such a broad level
it it's hard to say if there would be an
answer but um that's why i was saying in
this talk i want rewinding to mean this
particular thing write down as many
transcripts and in that setting like you
know this technique is a black box way
to lift classical proofs to the quantum
setting uh provided you have some sort
of collapsing style guarantee
um
maybe i'll leave it there and uh
yeah just um just just to so so i guess
yeah yeah leo was saying
if i understand right here you were
saying well how would you know
you know if if you had a if you had a if
you had a protocol which rebound only a
constant number of times
how would you know
uh
that you should you should use much
heavier
proof quantum security i would even know
that some somewhere in there there
wasn't something lurking exactly that's
the question exactly and may ask another
question so i i didn't completely follow
so how this how this uh
reduction to one or two rewinds work so
so
shouldn't shouldn't that require that
your
your error probability was was very
small and and you you were you were able
to
um your your quantum technique was able
to work with those smaller probabilities
so is that where the unruly technique
breaks down so
you know he deals with a constant number
of rewinds
but then
but then
you know why uh
okay so so is is it is is that where it
um
[Music]
you know why why it can't be applied
with this with this kind of
proof
i i have to say i i am not sure
unused technique cannot be a i'm not
sure understanding cannot be used if you
know so suppose all you want to prove is
that a kilian you can't treat with
probability 1 minus epsilon that's all
you want
that's all you care about and if if you
have that you're happy because then you
can you know repeat and so on so if all
you want is that you can't cheat
probability one minus epsilon i'm not a
hundred percent sure that you can't use
something simpler
of course i'm not going to get the
result they won't give you the result
that they give which is just the four
message killian
but it's not clear to me uh that that's
not possible oh i think that what's
going to happen though is you're going
to have such a terrible soundness there
that your sequential repetitions will
lose the the sickness
okay i'm not sure because of there's
only one rewinding it's not
i don't know it's i'm confused about
this issue
i have to say
so it's going to be like one over one
over witness length or something this is
what you're saying uh the soundless gap
so you have to like sort of do it
witness number of times to in order for
oh i mean the sound of this gap is
actually going to be really terrible
like it's going to be
uh
uh one over like pcp length actually
because what you need to do is be able
to invoke gentle measurement enough
times
like the the proposal right is to use
gentle measurement to just keep
rewinding and that works as long as your
approver was succeeding with probability
really really close to one
um but for this gentle measurement
you're going to have to measure
something like pcp number of times
actually maybe much worse because pcp
number of times is how many accepting
transcripts you need but you need to
there's also the blow up of like the
failing transcripts and so
it's going to be much worse than that
and then
you'll lose this thing when you
sequentially repeat but that's if you
wanna you because you're trying to get
an entire pcp but why you don't need to
get entire pcp only just find a
collision
you're working hard because you want to
find a pcp right you're saying aha look
i've you can't have a pcp because that's
not a language how can i have
why are you working sort of find a pcp i
have x all i want is a collision i'm
going to wind once and to run once it's
enough to
you know to have one minus
of something is not too bad
i i'm i'm i'm being provocative i i
don't know if it works but i'm that i'm
trying you know it's not clear to me
that it doesn't it's not clear to me
that you have to work so hard we don't
need your pcp
all i want is a collision i'm trying to
you know have a reduction not uh
if i can uh do my interrupts uh so
there is a pcp like uh appearing also in
this uh
gold alright proof right like it it is
like the way that you argue that the
thing is sound is you say okay the
reduction can't find the pcp but there
exists a pcp
that you know could be there whereas in
the quantum setting like
the adversary is not even a function
right in the
in the classical setting you can say the
adversary is a function from like
challenges to
to answers and so like the pcp is
contained in this function in some way
and the quantum setting this is not true
like the way the adversary behaves
depends on the order in which you query
things
because you know non-commuting and stuff
like that so i think this is sort of the
conceptual problem
um and so like any proof any
cryptographic proof that relies on the
adversary being a function might be like
might run into this kind of problem
right
i mean but the adversary is sort of a
function if you always think about the
sort of density matrix of the state of
the adversary and this actually has a
classical description and this sort of
completely sort of characterizes the
adversary what happens if you ask at a
query like you know any query that you
wanted the first query any query created
you want the second query and so on so i
mean is it about a function existing or
having access to it
um because
in some sense it does sort of exist so
long as
function do we doing next message
function
yeah even the next message function you
can def i mean so but then it's not a
function of its input you can rewind you
can rewind or duplicate the state or all
these things that you cannot actually do
in actuality but these things do exist
it's like the probability of the
adversary answers correctly on some or
you know some measurement outcome is
something this is this is sort of well
defined
given given adversarial stage you just
don't know how to access it
so so in a sense it is possible that the
adversary sort of that you can sort of
given the density matrix of of the
adversarial state it does somehow sort
of define a pcp but uh we want an
efficient red i mean because it's a it's
a computational assumption then you want
an efficient reduction so
uh
this is um well the obstacle i guess
maybe i'm just picking on a minor
point yeah
now so these uh i i guess um you know
good good questions i guess these things
get pretty delicate so
so uh
you know i
um
it would be um would be very interesting
to see whether whether one can make this
you know some simpler proof work but um
but
you know there's a lot there are a lot
of uh obstacles along the way
so uh good great point so
can we
as we go and would you would you like to
go next sure i can i can go next so
thanks a lot uh fermi and the echo the
compliments that we heard already um i
have three questions going from maybe
more concrete to maybe kind of abstract
and
funny crazy i don't know um so the first
concrete question and maybe this is a
long of what
along the lines of what yellow is saying
or or maybe you said it and it's just so
basic so why did you okay so
you're you're you're really opening up
the proof of the killian protocol and
looking to get the transcripts i mean
that was your or the looking to record
the responses that was your disclaimer
on slide 31.
um
what if instead we looked at the entire
protocol as a quantum process
and wanting all you want is one outcome
at the end like accept reject or maybe a
transcript i'm not sure exactly what or
maybe some input state that is
contradiction or something
why can't we just do the entire thing
quantumly and then
put like we want that event and then
amplify using uh watches recording like
kind of watches rewinding like a regular
another type of process
um
yeah good uh i think i see what you're
getting at um
i guess that maybe the difficulty
i'm seeing there like what is the event
going to be
um
like again i i can i can sure i can
purify the whole process like leave
everything into your position have an
adversary state only measure if the
verifier is convinced
never measure anything um
and then but now i need to define some
event to make what you're saying go
through right i don't see what the event
would be
is there a predicate like you had a
collision or or a pcb or something like
that
uh yeah but the collision predict is
hard to define because the that's sort
of like over over two executions like if
i over one execution i can't sort of uh
uh
compute this collision predicate if
there's no notion of a collision on a
single execution
goes back to the hypothetical experiment
that you could do
[Music]
yeah i guess all i'm saying is you know
i can run the whole adversary quantumly
compute anything i want about its
responses but the thing i cannot compute
about his responses is like
is there a collision because the
collisions are across two different
invocations and and that's where the
difficulty comes in
okay okay
um so yeah so another question is is
um what so it's really interesting when
we get to these quantum challenges
they're at the heart of it it's the no
cloning theorem and issues like well you
can't you can't clone therefore you
can't keep initial state or you can't
keep a transcript and whatnot and then i
found that often we when we were forced
to think of with a no cloning mindset we
were forced to rethink the original
definitions actually what do they really
mean so this happens in things like
semantic security um
i'm sure other ones too so i was
wondering um from that point of view is
there something that you learned that
you wanted to share of what is rewinding
what is a transcript what is um what was
caitlin's protocol actually doing at the
heart of it
yeah um
okay i think i
understand your question and maybe i'm
gonna give an answer that's a little
orthogonal to it but just something that
i learned about cloning
um
that uh
sort of in the early stages of this
project we're thinking well
the goal is to write down a pcp
right so
um
you know
just just write down any any valid pcp
so if that's the goal then sure we're
allowed to clone this state you can you
can write down the pcp inefficiently too
it's fine
um
but then the problem you run into there
this is like a really natural thing you
might try if you're faced with this
question of trying to prove security of
killian right just uh you know the
problem seems to be cloning but if
you're trying to get something
information theoretic just clone anyway
um the problem with that argument is
that uh
it doesn't work
and the reason is that um
when you just arbitrarily clone the
prover state you won't be able to appeal
to the computational assumptions anymore
and once you lose the ability to appeal
the computational assumptions because
you've cheated and used cloning then you
can no longer guarantee that the
responses you record are going to be
consistent so
it's not clear that you get a pcp now
and so like one thing that was useful to
think about like the early stages for
sort of uh like testing the different
ideas we had was just consider always
the prover who's just going to commit to
uniform superposition of all pcp strings
and you'd better come up with a strategy
that's actually going to narrow this
uniform super position down to a single
pcp string
and uh like it was sort of helpful to
think about this that like you know if
the approver committed to uniform
position of the strings
um
and i i extract one chunk of one you
like one random string and one chunk of
different random string it's really
useless for me is uh trying to get a
reduction
um
and for the other question of uh
um
you know
do we learn anything new about like
security guarantees
um
maybe in this particular setting i'm not
sure
if if like any of the
security definitions like ought to
change uh because like what we want here
is really we want the classical
definition we want that a verifier
cannot be convinced
and the only thing we want is if we want
this extra property that like also if
you have a quantum computer you can't
convince me
um
so
for that reasoning i i guess i don't see
um
you know any reason to sort of change
the the definition other than ask for
security against quantum adversaries but
i think um definitely when you have or
quantum inherently quantum
functionalities killian is not um like
that's when that question is like
much more meaningful
okay thanks um yeah my final one
maybe there's nothing to say really but
i was wondering if there's links of
non-local games just because when you
had the regulatory at some point and the
commitments it looks like you could
maybe reinforce this uh
this this this commitment idea with
separation of different parties
and uh you could like test the pcp with
multiple parties i guess probably people
done this before so um
yeah did that come up or
yeah it came up absolutely okay
yeah it came up and uh
uh actually like y'all might be more
qualified to speak about this because
she has a paper on this sort of
connection but um like one thing that
like we realized during this project was
that
um
like this killian protocol
is this uh like this four message
protocol so one question responds one
question response
um
and it turns out that if you use like
the
um
maybe i'll help you with this if i screw
this up but if you use like the right
hash function in kilian
if you replace the collisions and hash
function with a like an appropriate
um
so-called statistically binding hash
function that like binds to a few
positions
basically what's happening is what you
can imagine is the killian protocol is
actually doing the same protocol twice
like it's asking some pct questions and
getting answers and asking pcd questions
and getting answers but the first time
you do it it's encrypted
like there's this new perspective of
killian's protocol that you get from
plugging in a particular hash function
that you might want to plug in to prove
quantum security
and what turns out to be the case is
that the first two messages are actually
a known protocol uh this like bmw
heuristic that um klyroz and rothblim
proved secure for for these no signaling
pcps
um
so
this is like connection we realized
early on and then like well it doesn't
we get we get stuck at
the polynomial time computation with
this
um it's a limitation of this particular
approach
um
but that is one way that um
you know these uh
non-local games show up somehow in
in these protocols in this analysis
i just want to say i'm impressed
with how well you understand that
protocol
okay
awesome i got it i'm glad i asked
thanks great
thanks and so um zwika do you have
any comments yeah so i mean i think i
probably i probably um voiced myself
enough uh but uh just uh yeah again uh
also i want to thank fermi for the
enlightening talk um and maybe sort of
okay i have two things one is to sort of
go back to the beginning and sort of
really emphasize this this uh point that
for me was making that uh sort of
thinking about uh sort of classical
crypto against quantum adversary is more
than just sort of replacing factoring
with some uh with some sort of quantum
resilient problem and we really sort of
need to go back and look at our
definitions and this is sort of an
ongoing process
and then i guess there's a lot of
contributions by and by others uh to
sort of trying to understand what are
the right uh what are the right ways to
formalize um uh to formalize our
cryptographic notions in the quantum
setting and i think there's still um
some sort of work to be done there you
said okay what happens if it's vertical
what happens there is rewinding what
happens with this uh i mean i i don't
know that we still sort of have the the
sort of the complete the complete
picture of uh uh how we should think
about uh sort of modeling cryptography
in in in a quantum world um so this is
sort of i guess sort of an open-ended uh
and open-ended thing and i don't know
perhaps i don't know if it's related or
not but i guess the my my question to
fermi is like what are the certain
limitations of these techniques is there
like somewhere where you want to take it
and it doesn't work i don't know like uh
if the verifier has secret randomness or
things of this or does it um what sort
of what would you say is well the next
challenge or or maybe like even broader
um uh
what would be a broader version of a
result of this of the form that you were
talking about
um thanks vika that's a great question i
think you gave a great answer too it's
like
um
yeah one of the really big uh like
um you know next steps would be uh
what happens if the protocol is not
publicly verifiable um
and it's sort of inherent for all of
this because um
okay maybe it wasn't clear in this talk
where i'm using this property but
throughout all this i want to say that
like anything that the security
reduction could do
the the adversary could do too
uh i'm sort of using this crucially to
to say that therefore the security
reduction can't break assumptions can't
break collapsing blah blah blah
um
so yeah all bets are off when uh you
have a privately verifiable protocol
because
now even like
estimating success probability or
even before that just seeing if you you
convince the verifier as hard um but
like every part of this technique seems
to like fundamentally rely on
um
you know having public verifiability and
so
uh you know one place where you'd we'd
really like to
maybe use these techniques and try to
understand security would be um
the mahada protocol right
uh you know where it seems like a closer
of right for this kind of analysis it's
a protocol where you want to use
parallel repetition it's already has the
collapsing property in some sense
um
and yet we just it doesn't apply because
the protocol isn't publicly verifiable
so that's that's one thing where um
you know it'd be nice to see there's any
connections but it's unclear at the
moment so so uh so sorry the mis what's
the connection between parallel
repetition property and the rewinding is
there um
like if you could do rewind if you could
do like uh your your technique for for
uh uh verifiers with with uh which are
not publicly verifiable then you would
be able to also get uh parallel
repetition is is there a connection
there or formula oh yeah yeah so um
one like one concept of this work is
that like parallel repetition for
publicly verifiable collapsing protocols
just works as you want it to
um
like you can take like gmw uh
instantiate the commitments with
quantumly binding commitments
and you can prove the parallel
repetition soundness is what you want it
to be
um
uh using this rewinding technique
um
and it's a
um
yeah it's sort of unclear how um
you know if you can say anything like
that when they're privately verifiable
um
okay
sorry what i think what i'm saying like
makes it sound very like crazy this is
doable but it if you really stare at it
i think it's like maybe it's really
easier than proving killian's results
um
so vinod has a question
hi hi fermi um so
you know the the question i have is how
general is a class of publicly
verifiable protocols that um your proof
applies to
um
so you just you just said if i
understand right that there is a there
is an example of a privately verifiable
protocol where you know your techniques
won't apply and that's formulas uh
protocol but how general do you capture
all publicly verifiable protocols for
example or
um good great question um
so uh
maybe this wasn't like an earlier draft
of the paper and because i checked
recently and it's not there for some
reason um but we kind of did try to
characterize the class of protocols we
could handle
um and the characteristics you need are
first that the security is argued by
rewinding one round
so we one one thing we did we didn't do
in this paper is uh
so um
uh is just uh prove that like iop
version of killian is sound like that's
actually that's actually open
um like we have not tried super hard but
it is like a sort of natural thing you
might want to prove
um
uh and it might be pretty easy you
really have not looked at it
um so first off there's like a round
restriction like it needs to be a
question answer around and that should
be it
maybe some rounds before it but
um
second restriction publicly verifiable
uh third restriction
it needs to have this collapsing
property
and that property can be weakened a
little bit
um
the way i phrase it today is that
you know the adversary can't tell
just uh the adversary thinks that when
you measure its answer that actually a
binary output measurement was performed
on its state
right i was saying this is crucial
um but you can imagine a weaker version
of collapsing that says that it can't
tell if a polynomial output measurement
was applied to the to the state
like there's sort of maybe no reason to
restrict to just two output measurements
it turns out that this technique can
handle the disturbance from a poly
outcome measurement applied to a state
so you can imagine like a definition of
like weekly collapsing that says that
the full measurement looks like a not
too disturbing measurement you can
handle that too so okay so so out of the
last two restrictions which of them is
is inherent do you think because
urumula's protocol if i understand right
is neither collapsing nor publicly
verifiable
um right or maybe you're missing
something
the hash function is collapsing it's
collapsing right it's implied by the
fact that it's in distinguishable
injective mode and the injected mode you
can measure
and uh so if it looks like the injective
motion
so it really is publicly repliable that
uh thanks
yeah sorry there's one more condition
um and there's one the last condition is
that it has to have some kind of like
special soundness property
like that's what the proof is doing it's
generating a lot of transcripts right
right but the key thing though is that
you have to be like to to phrase as well
the you you should generalize special
soundness a little bit because killian's
protocol is not special sound
right like think about the definition of
special soundness it says
any collection of transcripts with
different challenges will be enough to
break soundness right but with killian's
protocol i can give you a whole bunch of
transcripts that only open a small
fraction of the pcp and that's useless
right but what you need is actually this
like your average case notion of special
soundness that says that like you know
if i send this adversary a whole bunch
of random strings and it opens it gives
me correct answers on a small fraction a
non-trivial fraction of them yeah then i
can that's going to break the soundness
and that's the notion of soundness that
killian satisfies and this generalizes
standard special soundness i think
that's basically the limit of what this
technique gives you
okay thanks
great
you know i think we are
um
yeah just about at the end of end of the
time for the panel is is there any are
there any other
comments that anyone wants to make
quickly
um
anybody on the panel
okay great well thanks thanks very much
thanks for me for a great talk and
thanks yael zika and
for wonderful comments and thank you for
being here
thank you umish this was a really really
great day for me it was wonderful really
i had a great time
thank you so much for coming this is fun
thank you very much for the to the
organizers and the speaker yeah
great thank you
you